have you heard of the save imma norway
masjid project your brothers and sisters
at islam that are establishing a one of
his kind masjid tawa and community
center in the capital of norway and they
need our urgent support now every person
that accepts islam through the center
every revert who learns about their deen
and calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video assalamu
alaikum brothers and sisters welcome to
salaam foreign we're
i'm not going to accept islam how do you
know that um what have i heard like
throughout some like youtube videos some
some youtube videos yeah uh some like i
think on the christian side people say
like islam is not the true religion yeah
one thing is like you see when muhammad
received the command from gabriel yeah
some christians said i was satan so i i
take that as like it was yeah yeah okay
no problem that's okay so let's assess
that
if i bring you the truth would you
accept it
uh
i don't know then how can i have an uh
dialogue when
i'm being told that even if i bring the
truth
if i come and tell you the sky is blue
and if if you say to me i don't know
then how can i have a dialogue because
you're basically saying even if you tell
me a fact
i'll still be double-minded
so i have to make sure i need to clear
that from the get-go because if if
you're telling me that even if i bring
you an evidence that my t-shirt is white
you're telling me i'll still be in doubt
yeah
then how can i have a title
so are you ready to accept the truth you
want to follow what you i i want to
follow christianity because i then then
if that's the case then there's no point
i'm going to tell them yeah yeah that's
fine yeah
it's good to see you
christian don't i mean it's very very
simple brothers and sisters don't care
if somebody is saying i'm not gonna come
here and waste my time jesus christ i'm
telling him if i give you the truth
would you accept it i know i wouldn't
why would i talk why would i waste my
time this is very very important guys
about the prophet peace be upon him when
he was talking with the quraish and he
was trying his best to convince him
but allah tells him that indeed you know
when he frowned to the blind man the
blind man was open to receive the
message and he wanted to know more he
was even a muslim
but the prophet peace be upon him was
too occupied with the grace why because
he wanted them to accept islam out of
his love his mercy but the message here
is what
if somebody doesn't want to hear i
haven't got time for that
i will talk to people who want to learn
if i say to somebody if i prove to you
this is why would you accept and he says
to me
no i'm not sure i haven't got time for
that i would rather spend time with
people who are more sincere and who are
looking for the truth wherever it is not
i believe this is the truth and even if
you bring me god shows me so i'm not
going to accept it in surah abbas allah
subhanahu ta'ala makes it very clear
that give your time to those who
want it and those who are genuinely
looking for advice and don't
make yourself
tired and exhausted by chasing a group
of people who are not going to change
have you heard of the save ima norway
masjid project your brothers and sisters
at islam that are establishing a one of
his kind masjid taowa and community
center in the capital of norway and they
need our urgent support now every person
that accepts islam through this center
every rivert who learns about their deen
and calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video